kevin in los angeles
is going to start this hour off hey
kevin how are you
hey dave hey john how are you guys today
great man how can we help
yes so uh my question is so my parents
are trying to pressure my uh
my new fiance and i to purchase a house
we just recently signed a two-year lease
for an apartment here in los angeles
collectively we make about 160 000
uh no debt and they're trying to
pressure us to buy uh some sort of
townhouse here in l.a about 500 to 600
000 uh with hoas about 400 a month and
we're just baffled is how we're supposed
to afford this
and um we're just kind of going back and
forth from that we'd like to
run out our lease of two years and pile
up some money and and
just look at that situation that okay
so when are you getting married um
ideally probably at the end of the year
okay um
so set a date and when you're married
the two of you there's an old-fashioned
biblical phrase
okay that a a lady when she leaves her
father's household
a gentleman when he leaves his mommy's
household is supposed to
leave the household
and cleave to their new spouse
cleave old english word right
and you gather what that means that the
two of you now are
a household when you're married right
and then that means john that their
parents
yeah they your your parents don't get a
vote man
um it's like the loney's favorite like
just
it's it's it's it's incredible to me and
i do it too on
how many people we let speak in at to
our lives to
give us insight and opinions on things
that and just
they don't it doesn't matter where i was
taking a poll
that's that's right so yeah they don't
get a vote man
um they don't get a vote if you're
making 160 grand how old are you
i am 29 and she is 26. so you're like
grown people y'all are killing it
yeah go get married this weekend man
y'all are killing it
and um you're playing house just go get
married you're already there
y'all signed a two-year lease you're
committed to this deal um
have a good corona wedding that'll save
you guys about fifty thousand dollars
and you can blame it on the on the
pandemic blame it on john deloney blame
it on some hack
on the radio that's right
um clearly you guys are good y'all know
what you're doing you make great money
you're
you're good employees and so and then it
just says mom and dad
thanks for your input we love you we
appreciate that you love us and i know
you mean well
but that's not our plan right now our
plan is we're going to rent for a little
while and pile up some cash and that's
what we want to do and
you know you're welcome to come over for
dinner though that's right 500 grand
for a 600 grand for a town home
so my texas real estate head that's
about 500
i mean there's listen you said three
times pressure us
hmm you said three times
pressure us and so
just be released from the pressure they
don't get a vote
i mean any more than you're walking down
the street and a stranger walks up and
goes hey buy a townhouse
you know it's like right you know you
just don't you know you don't get a vote
you know what if i told you to buy i
don't get a vote
i get to give input because you asked
but i mean
i mean what if you just picked up the
phone and there was a guy on the other
end said buy a townhouse you know
no i'm not doing that you know so mom
and dad love you and they mean well and
that's where that's how they get a
footing to place pressure
but they are getting ready to learn a
new skill and it's called being
parents to adults and it is a
very difficult skill to learn believe me
i know
i have three wonderfully functional
adult kids with wonderfully functional
households and spouses
and i spend an amazing amount of my
personal emotional energy not
interfering in their lives and i know
that they probably spend a lot of
emotional energy
trying to appreciate that trying to
navigate that
so kevin you're you're going to be
married soon if you and your
new wife can come up with ways to honor
your mom
honor your dad honor her your your
wife's parents
and at the same time establish those
boundaries moving forward this is gonna
show up at thanksgiving this kind of
stuff is
uh well of course y'all gonna be here
for christmas right and maybe y'all
aren't maybe i'll go on a trip somewhere
this will this will play out for the
rest of your relationship
so start now um honoring the people
putting input into your life that you
don't really
want or ask for or don't think is wise
love them because they're trying to love
you
and then get together with your with
your soon-to-be new wife and y'all make
decisions on your own and move forward
yeah you take a deep breath
you smile and you say i love you
thank you for caring about me i
appreciate your input
but we're gonna do this because this is
what we've already decided that's right
and um thank you though we're going to
sit put
for a couple of years you know you just
you don't have to be mean about it
you don't have to cause a fight you
don't have to go you don't have any
right to speak
into my life you don't have to do that
all you got to just say no
we're good thanks i'm removing the
voting booth that's right
and maybe say i'm going to pile up cash
and so in two years i'm going to have
a couple hundred grand to put down on
something cooler than a town
right they don't get to tell you who
vote for president either they don't
parents like to pitch in on that one man
they don't get to tell you how to
cook his favorite recipe they don't
they don't that one's dangerous that
one's real dangerous
when he was a little boy he liked it
made this way my parents death
yeah my parents tell a great story about
mom really tried to learn this special
dish
oh really what happens in every
household you know that oh man
and after the first time they got
married she he was like oh god what are
you doing
because he went from his mom's house to
my mom's house and
man they it was a good conversation they
had yeah
let's talk about meals together it's um
it's that that's
yeah so just these are called boundaries
if you really struggle with it pick up
dr henry cloud's book boundaries it is
the quintessential
book on the subject and you will read it
and smile
while you're reading and you go oh i
know these people
they're everyone some of them are toxic
most of them mean well though
most of them mean well yeah and it's
just learning to say
you know we're not going to do that this
time at thanksgiving and
um you know i invite my sons-in-law to
do stuff with me from time to time
sometimes they do it sometimes they
don't right and
you know they just get to decide it's
just
instead of me telling them what to do
you know and moms and dads out there
we're used to telling them what to do
that's right and it was easier when we
just told them what to do
when i was physically bigger than them
right and they had to do what i said
right
that's right i i want to impress on moms
and dads out there
ask permission can i can i toss you a
recommendation about real estate
invite yourself into the conversation it
will make boundary development for your
kids as they're entering into their new
adulthood
you know what i did that i didn't even
realize i did it like the kids are
building a house that's a gift
and i just said you know i got an idea
do you mind if i tell you i
did instead of just going you need to
put that over there that is such a gift
dave what a gift
i don't even mean to i'm proud of myself
hey if you keep working on it dave
you're going to get there
eventually eventually i'll get there ask
the kids they'll tell you the truth